I wish you good fortune in the wars to
come here Chris I wish you good fortune
in the wars to come I wish you good
fortune in the wars to come
good fortune in the wars to come
everybody this is going to be my episode
5 QA careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet there were a lot of
magnificent 7 comments especially
questions about the logic of going north
of the wall to get a white and bring it
back to prove to Cersei what's going on
but the best crowd-sourced answer that
I've seen everybody commenting on the
best theory is that they started out
with this moment here they wanted to do
this scene and then worked in Reverse
for that like what would it take to get
all these characters north of the wall
so however you feel about the twist
that's probably the why behind it and a
lot of you also noted a similarity in
that Jon Snow quote I wish you good
fortune in the wars to come when he said
that Daenerys before leaving it was very
ominous it was the same thing that Mance
Rayder said to Stannis before he ended
up dying and it was the same thing in
the flashbacks that Arthur Dayne said to
Ned Stark before he ended up dying so
you could draw your own conclusion about
what might happen to Jon Snow but like I
said he is critical for the plot so
whatever happens to him I think he is
walking away from season 7 just fine but
here we go
ok so questions Daniel asks do you think
that someone will sacrifice themselves
to become a white Walker so I assume
you're talking about turn into a white
like you're talking about a white so
they can bring them south of the wall no
I don't expect anybody from our band to
become a white that would be crazy
tragic if one of these seven wound up
being the proof to Cersei that the army
of the Dead really did exist so while
I'm not expecting that there was that
weird clip with Dan and Dave talking
about the hand that they tried to take
the King's Landing after the person
turned in the Nights Watch south of the
wall they had to kill it they're like
okay we need to prove to the kingdom
that this is happening we need to get
more help more men send this decomposing
hand to King's Landing but they said by
the time the hand got there it had
decomposed into nothingness so it wasn't
effective proof so they need to bring
something that won't decompose before
they get there but I don't think it has
to be so fresh that it literally just
got turned I think they could take any
of these that are sort of half
decomposed with some flesh hanging off
them I think that'd be fine next
question Geordi I think that's how you
pronounce your name am I the only one
that noticed the Mount
from the scene of the children the
forest making the night king in the
arrowhead mountain from the episode six
trailer are they the same mountain yes
they do look very similar I don't know
if they're intending that to be the same
mountain though the same location back
when that original episode aired and
they were turning him into the night
gained a lot of people thought that that
might be the Isle of faces because
that's where the pact with the first men
was later signed but because this is
before the long night started and before
the wall was created it's totally
possible that this is actually north of
the wall where they're going so there's
a good chance that's correct there's
really no confirmation the producers
haven't said anything about it and the
other thing too is that a lot of
locations in Game of Thrones end up
doubling up for similar locations but
there are only so many places that you
can go to film scenes like this so it
could just be a coincidence but I do
think that this is happening
further north so I think it's more
likely that this is a very similar place
but we don't really know what the north
looked like before the long night
started so you just have to remember
that even before the long night and
before the White Walkers in the night
King the season's still change just like
they do today so the north probably
would have been frozen then too so I
don't think that this is the exact same
place next question Green asks what are
your thoughts on the theories that the
cat's paw dagger could be Lightbringer
well in order for that to be true you'd
actually have to plunge it into
someone's heart there's a couple more
steps in it becoming Lightbringer it is
totally possible but the thing is is
remember the prophecy the prince who has
promised got that big twist this season
where they're like maybe it could be a
princess instead of a prince or it could
be more than one person which I actually
think is the case so I think you know
when Melisandre said prophecies are
tricky things the idea that they're
trying to get across is that there are
multiple special people like azor Ahai
type figures meaning that there are
multiple types of Lightbringer items so
you have barracks Lightbringer like he
lights his sword on fire in the trailer
here but Jon Snow also has long claw you
have the Valyrian dagger you have the
Dragons that are also kind of like
flaming swords so I just think there are
multiple light bringers so you're not
wrong when you say the dagger could be
Lightbringer it's just that it's one of
many next question Nelson asks why do
you think Jon doesn't want the nares to
know he got resurrected and how
she react when she finds out well I
think he just doesn't want to freak her
out like he doesn't really know how to
treat all this supernatural stuff and
he's a little mistrustful of it and I'm
actually expecting Daenerys to be
somewhat relieved because she was reborn
in that fire when she burned her baby in
Khal Drogo both she and the dragons were
born anew so they wanted his crazy
traumatic supernatural experience so I
think she'll be pleasantly surprised
that someone's been through something
similar
and it'll just reinforce the idea that
she believes that Jon Snow is special
next question so I didn't get your name
because I pulled this from the DMS but
it was a pretty common question did
anybody see how concerned Dani was when
John said he was going north of the wall
I think she's developed feelings for him
why is nobody talking about and so the
funny thing about this is that everybody
is talking about it there's you know
fifty fifty people are really excited
about it or people are really upset
about it because of the implications so
it should go without saying yes Daenerys
is John snows on they share genetic
material Targaryen have Wed brother to
sister Aegon sister wives to sisters for
hundreds of years to keep the bloodline
pure and keep their connection with the
dragons so it's totally natural if
people are upset by this it would be
weird if you're really excited about
Jaime and Cersei hooking up on the show
but given their history I would be
surprised that people didn't think that
the show was also going this direction
as well but I think the real
conversation now is to talk about what
their chemistry is like on story is it
believable because the show is relying
on them together on-screen increasingly
so their scenes didn't work it would be
a big problem for Season eight and I
think that they've done a pretty good
job so far so I think it's okay but
we'll see we have a couple more episodes
we'll just continued to see how that
develops next question Ryan as said John
wasn't burned alive by the dragon
because he's a Targaryen does that mean
that Tyrion is also a Targaryen I know
people are still asking about Tyrion
potentially being targeted I don't think
that's the case I think it's just the
Dragons trusting them the books get a
little more specific about it but it
seems like what the TV show is doing is
just showing that the Dragons trust or
do not trust people and it's not really
like a genetic bond Scituate
like Daenerys has a connection to them
because she gave birth to them so they
think of her as their mother and Drogo
just senses something special in John
that he's a special person so it's the
show's way of winking at his heritage in
the Dragons when they were trusting
Tyrion didn't look like this like it
almost looks like a dog cooing up to its
master like please Pet me I'm really
excited to see you it would be a very
different conversation if one of the
Dragons snuggled up next to Tyrion
inserted budding him with its head like
a dog would then we could start
wondering about Terrans heritage next
question Colin asks when Cersei said she
was pregnant the first thing I thought
was that it was a hint to her having
less than nine months to live it sounds
like you're talking about Cersei Maggie
the frogs that you would have three
children not for after all so I assume
you're talking about Cersei or maybe
you're talking about the baby - yes a
lot of people were wondering about the
Maggie prophecy and I still think the
show will find a way to prove that true
there's still a lot of questions about
valonqar how is Jaime going to
eventually kill Cersei because
everyone's like yeah it's got to have
something to do with Jaime's character
so it's possible that in impregnating
her he could also lead to her eventual
death that would be a really messed-up
fulfillment of the valonqar prophecy the
little brother Jaime kills Cersei with
the baby the literal symbol of the very
twisted bond that they share so let's
just call this a new offshoot of the
valonqar
but again I don't think that surgery's
going to die this season I do think that
her death will have something to do with
Jaime it would be blasphemous if she
died and Jaime were nowhere around and
had nothing to do with it next question
Kix lolly asks do you think that Cersei
will attempt to punish Bronn for
betraying Jaime I actually read this as
kill Bronn for betraying Jaime but she
actually asked him to take care of him
for betraying him right after she said
that - she said never betray me again so
he has a big choice to make does he
execute Bronn like Cersei implied she
wanted or does he betray her I don't
think the bronz going anywhere in next
week's episode so this is going to be a
finale type thing but I think it's just
one more reason for Jaime to take off TV
show Jaime has been taking crazy pills
for a long time now I think
people are getting frustrated with them
for continuing to go back to Cersei so
given all the things that bran has done
and all the moments they've shared the
season it just stands to reason that he
would refuse to execute brought in the
way that he refused to allow Tyrion to
die and freed him so I think we'll wind
up with a similar situation he'll go
against Cersei next question RIA asked
did Gilly bring the scroll with her
which proves the marriage between
Rhaegar and Lyanna I hope she just
didn't leave it there I think the idea
is that Samwell took all the books that
he thought were relevant to helping them
fight the war for the dawn so I'm
assuming that she took all that stuff
too I think the idea is that they're
just revealing information casually like
oh by the way did you know dot dot dot
big plot Bom these two people got
married meaning that your friend over
here has a legitimate claim to the Iron
Throne so right now I really don't see a
situation where Jon Snow is vying for
the Iron Throne and needs to prove that
he's a legitimate to the other Lords I
feel like it's only important to us the
fans because we're like we want to know
is Jon Snow the legitimate son of
Rhaegar and Lyanna next question brento
asks so I already answered the drogon
question so I'll say the hammer the
Kendra is using in the episode is that
the same as Robert Baratheon during the
rebellion no it's not the same I
actually included a picture to my video
this is what it looks like
gendry's is a little bit smaller I think
that's mostly for practical reasons but
I'm not an expert in ancient weapons so
you guys can let me know do you think
that this weapon would be more effective
than this weapon in the battle it feels
like you'd have to be legit huge and
strong to be able to swing this around
effectively otherwise you'd wind up with
an aria situation fighting Brienne like
you have this big sword being swung
around it's easier to dodge the person
who's quicker with the more agile
weapons is able to land the kill before
you can get another big swing in they
definitely wanted to look like Robert's
Warhammer like he even has a stag on it
there it's amazing the Lannister
soldiers never spotted that I guess he
did say that they didn't pay attention
to him like they just picked their armor
up and left they treated him like
garbage but thank you so much for
submitting questions it's always a ton
of fun to do so what's going to happen
is because we're in the last couple of
weeks once we get to that last episode
there'll be a couple extra videos just
sort of wrapping the season up and then
start talking about season 8 stuff we'll
have all the theories there are people
that think that season 8 stuff has
leaked it has not there is no actual
information from the scripts for season
8 even though they're done so if someone
tells you that they already have season
8 episode 1 spoilers you know that they
are absolutely full of [ __ ] but just
a heads up - if you're not seeing your
comments land it's because YouTube is a
little buggy right now the videos that
I've been doing for Game of Thrones this
season are literally the most watched
videos that I've ever done on my channel
each one is like one of my most viewed
videos ever so they're just getting
pounded by the comments and YouTube is
just breaking a little bit but they're
all landing so even if you don't see
your comment it still landed and you're
still included in all the giveaway stuff
so no worries there and don't forget
that defenders is dropping this Friday
on Netflix so I'll be posting some
defenders videos later this week - will
leave all your requests for bonus videos
later this week bye next Game of Thrones
video will be on Thursday or Friday and
I'll say congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner
Nakia taki please private message me on
the back end of my channel so I can get
your contact details you can click here
to watch that trailer again and you can
click here for my episode 5 video thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you